Now you can buy McDonald's for one dollar.
And therefore, the preparation that we had by our mothers
is turning out to be maladaptive.
The same preparation that was supposed to protect us from hunger and famine
is going to cause obesity,
cardiovascular problems and metabolic disease.
So this concept that genes could be marked by our experience,
and especially the early life experience,
can provide us a unifying explanation
of both health and disease.
But is true only for rats?
The problem is, we cannot test this in humans,
because ethically, we cannot administer child adversity in a random way.
So if a poor child develops a certain property,
we don't know whether this is caused by poverty
or whether poor people have bad genes.
So geneticists will try to tell you that poor people are poor
because their genes make them poor.
Epigeneticists will tell you
poor people are in a bad environment or an impoverished environment
that creates that phenotype, that property.
So we moved to look into our cousins, the monkeys.
My colleague, Stephen Suomi, has been rearing monkeys
in two different ways:
randomly separated the monkey from the mother
and reared her with a nurse
and surrogate motherhood conditions.
So these monkeys didn't have a mother; they had a nurse.
And other monkeys were reared with their normal, natural mothers.
And when they were old, they were completely different animals.
The monkeys that had a mother did not care about alcohol,
they were not sexually aggressive.
The monkeys that didn't have a mother were aggressive, were stressed
and were alcoholics.
So we looked at their DNA early after birth, to see:
Is it possible that the mother is marking?
Is there a signature of the mother in the DNA of the offspring?
These are Day-14 monkeys,
and what you see here is the modern way by which we study epigenetics.
We can now map those chemical marks, which we call methylation marks,
on DNA at a single nucleotide resolution.
We can map the entire genome.
We can now compare the monkey that had a mother or not.
And here's a visual presentation of this.
What you see is the genes that got more methylated are red.
The genes that got less methylated are green.
You can see many genes are changing,
because not having a mother is not just one thing --
it affects the whole way;
it sends signals about the whole way your world is going to look
when you become an adult.
And you can see the two groups of monkeys
extremely well-separated from each other.
How early does this develop?
These monkeys already didn't see their mothers,
so they had a social experience.
Do we sense our social status, even at the moment of birth?
So in this experiment, we took placentas of monkeys
that had different social status.
What's interesting about social rank is that across all living beings,
they will structure themselves by hierarchy.
Monkey number one is the boss;
monkey number four is the peon.
You put four monkeys in a cage,
there will always be a boss and always be a peon.
And what's interesting is that the monkey number one
is much healthier than monkey number four.
And if you put them in a cage,
monkey number one will not eat as much.
Monkey number four will eat [a lot].
And what you see here in this methylation mapping,
a dramatic separation at birth
of the animals that had a high social status
versus the animals that did not have a high status.
So we are born already knowing the social information,
and that social information is not bad or good,
it just prepares us for life,
because we have to program our biology differently
if we are in the high or the low social status.
But how can you study this in humans?
We can't do experiments, we can't administer adversity to humans.
But God does experiments with humans,
and it's called natural disasters.
One of the hardest natural disasters in Canadian history
happened in my province of Quebec.
It's the ice storm of 1998.
We lost our entire electrical grid because of an ice storm
when the temperatures were, in the dead of winter in Quebec,
minus 20 to minus 30.
And there were pregnant mothers during that time.
And my colleague Suzanne King followed the children of these mothers
for 15 years.
And what happened was, that as the stress increased --
and here we had objective measures of stress:
How long were you without power? Where did you spend your time?
Was it in your mother-in-law's apartment or in some posh country home?
So all of these added up to a social stress scale,
and you can ask the question:
How did the children look?
And it appears that as stress increases,
the children develop more autism,
they develop more metabolic diseases
and they develop more autoimmune diseases.
We would map the methylation state,
and again, you see the green genes becoming red as stress increases,
the red genes becoming green as stress increases,
an entire rearrangement of the genome in response to stress.
So if we can program genes,
if we are not just the slaves of the history of our genes,
that they could be programmed, can we deprogram them?
Because epigenetic causes can cause diseases like cancer,
metabolic disease
and mental health diseases.
Let's talk about cocaine addiction.
Cocaine addiction is a terrible situation
that can lead to death and to loss of human life.
We asked the question:
Can we reprogram the addicted brain
to make that animal not addicted anymore?
We used a cocaine addiction model
that recapitulates what happens in humans.
In humans, you're in high school,
some friends suggest you use some cocaine,
you take cocaine, nothing happens.
Months pass by, something reminds you of what happened the first time,
a pusher pushes cocaine,
and you become addicted and your life has changed.
In rats, we do the same thing.
My colleague, Gal Yadid,
he trains the animals to get used to cocaine,
then for one month, no cocaine.
Then he reminds them of the party when they saw the cocaine the first time
by cue, the colors of the cage when they saw cocaine.
And they go crazy.
They will press the lever to get cocaine
until they die.
We first determined that the difference between these animals
is that during that time when nothing happens,
there's no cocaine around,
their epigenome is rearranged.
Their genes are re-marked in a different way,
and when the cue comes, their genome is ready
to develop this addictive phenotype.
So we treated these animals with drugs that either increase DNA methylation,
which was the epigenetic marker to look at,
or decrease epigenetic markings.
And we found that if we increased methylation,
these animals go even crazier.
They become more craving for cocaine.
But if we reduce the DNA methylation,
the animals are not addicted anymore.
We have reprogrammed them.
And a fundamental difference between an epigenetic drug
and any other drug
is that with epigenetic drugs,
we essentially remove the signs of experience,
and once they're gone,
they will not come back unless you have the same experience.
The animal now is reprogrammed.
So when we visited the animals 30 days, 60 days later,
which is in human terms many years of life,
they were still not addicted -- by a single epigenetic treatment.
So what did we learn about DNA?
DNA is not just a sequence of letters;
it's not just a script.
DNA is a dynamic movie.
Our experiences are being written into this movie, which is interactive.
You're, like, watching a movie of your life, with the DNA,
with your remote control.
You can remove an actor and add an actor.
And so you have, in spite of the deterministic nature of genetics,
you have control of the way your genes look,
and this has a tremendous optimistic message
for the ability to now encounter some of the deadly diseases
like cancer, mental health,
with a new approach,
looking at them as maladaptation.
And if we can epigenetically intervene,
[we can] reverse the movie by removing an actor
and setting up a new narrative.
So what I told you today is,
our DNA is really combined of two components,
two layers of information.
One layer of information is old,
evolved from millions of years of evolution.
It is fixed and very hard to change.
The other layer of information is the epigenetic layer,
which is open and dynamic
and sets up a narrative that is interactive,
that allows us to control, to a large extent, our destiny,
to help the destiny of our children
and to hopefully conquer disease
and serious health challenges
that have plagued humankind for a long time.
So even though we are determined
by our genes,
we have a degree of freedom
that can set up our life to a life of responsibility.
Thank you.
(Applause)